would you mind just for a second if
everybody would just stand up and kind
of shake it out a little bit in about 30
minutes
might say hello to the person next to
you shake their hand you know
a hammer starts there's a lot of math on
Twitter that you should write a can
tweet all right thanks for having us
here this morning I always consider it
an equal exchange to to interact with
fervent minds so with minds that are
fertile ground entrepreneurs I've been
an entrepreneur I shouldn't frame it
like this but I will before you were
born I've been an entrepreneur my first
job was when I was eight years old and I
started with the open days when I was
nine years old I was around a very
innovative owner and baseball who
thought baseball was boring he thought
the game was so boring that even he had
a rabbit pop out the ground and hand the
umpire the baseball's instead of just a
traditional get it out of the bucket he
thought that he was so stubborn as an
owner that it would be good that a mule
would be his mascot he bought the mule
into the hotel during baseball league
meetings he took the game of baseball
from traditional uniforms to colored
uniforms he innovated the designated
hitter he hired track stars for the
playoffs in the World Series go right
over to Cal Berkeley and take a track
star and pay him $100,000 just so in
case we made the World Series and we
need to steal second base he didn't even
have to know how to play baseball just
still second base so I've been around
innovators and innovation all my life
I'm very a serial entrepreneur and I
understand the mindset of an
entrepreneur and so I'll try to make
this as valuable as I can from that
standpoint and also from the standpoint
of social media and in particular social
media optimization versus search engine
optimization just real quick over the
surface in 30,000 foot view
earlier I put up I put up see her face
which was it's like what is that right
because of social media it is so much
easier the bar of entry this is strictly
for entrepreneurs and thinking of
starting businesses the old model of
having to raise X amount of dollars of
angel capital and then you know get
ready for your VC round before you even
get there today you can use all of these
social media tools to see if you really
have something right and insert yourself
into the conversation so what I choose
this arm I have a song on a project that
I'm working on and it's called see her
face when I finished the song I said
well see her face okay I made a big
dance party record that was optimized
for an audience that may also love
fashion so waiting so rather than
waiting until after the song has
received a certain amount of gross
impressions and other media around it I
decided to create the media of myself
and insert myself into the fashion world
without spending a dollar and why not
shoot for the top sense other people now
pay for the content in other words for
me to source the content that I needed
for my launch into the fashion world all
I had to do was go to YouTube it didn't
take long I didn't have to go out and
shoot the video I didn't have to cut the
deal with the models I don't have to do
any of that at the same time I'm making
it aware to DNG Versace if we go down
the page you'll see product that I'm
going to make available not only the
events the songs and the social media
campaign for these brands but I'm gonna
create a destination that they can go to
around an actual brand see her face
because obviously although it's
superficial models start with the outer
appearance and then well I guess in
models we don't ever get into
necessarily to depth but but
haha but that's not to say it's not any
substance there but we have to be real
right so initially we start with the
outer appearance and then they clothed
them in all these great designs later on
for a lot of you who are fashion
oriented take a look at what's on there
and this is all 2010 stuff so you'll see
the spring and summer collections but
the point that I'm making is as an
entrepreneur and this being entrepreneur
week and focusing on the tools of social
media it took me at I think I used yeah
I use blogspot I should even say I think
I use blogspot I use blogspot for a very
particular reason I found out that
within the Google search engine when you
use blogspot it's optimized so in the
search returned it comes to the top so
it wasn't an accident so is that why you
it's very important it's very important
and so if you look and by the way the
Twitter optimization works the same way
so if you look on Twitter for those of
you on right now if you Twitter blast 24
you'll see a lot of MC Hammer come up
around blast 24 but what is that well
what I'm doing is I'm doing two things
I've already began to see the content
the content was sourced again from
places like YouTube and other places
with video ultimately I want to build a
destination for citizen journalism we
were talking about social good earlier
now this is another startup I'm doing
but I'm not doing it with the
traditional model these tools have
lowered the bar of entry and the bar of
entry now is here it's really in how
active you are earlier I heard the deans
say that it reminded me a lot of a music
conference obviously had a couple weeks
ago at the Grammys I said you know
social media and all these new tools are
not the end-all they're not going to
supplement and as a generalized
corporate statement it's very true but
on many levels I would challenge you on
that because a lot of things are going
to be replaced because of the real-time
access of these platforms and we don't
even have time to go and pick up per se
a newspaper when I can just whip out
my iPhone or my Android platform and go
boom boom and it's right there so who's
gonna provide that information to me
recommendation is going to go further
beyond the traditional here's a paper
and here's the headlines I want to know
what you're reading which is why
trending topics are so popular follow
lists and so forth so what I'm
encouraging all your entrepreneurs in
the room and I'm like Lloyd earlier when
only half the room raised their hand on
entrepreneurship I'm always taken aback
because to have the opportunity in this
model this is the greatest opportunity
ever to be an entrepreneur this time
right now the down economy actually
works in your favor whenever a company
like Intel I was at the Intel CEO 600 I
did the keynote for them two years ago
but this year I was there one of the
things that they do as a company during
a down market is they double up on all
of their investments on all of their
bets they double down in a down market
so in a down market there's a great
opportunity one of the things that I
love doing I said this earlier I'm going
to extend a conversation I like working
with great companies and I like working
with distressed companies the distressed
companies who need social media to tell
their story to regain ground and to to
communicate their message there's a
great opportunity in that because as you
as you can see from the FCC across the
board there's always a problem there's
always lawsuits there's always
challenges and the other side of the
story needs to be told so there's three
sides right your side their side and the
truth well if you are actually telling
the story yourself the transparency is
what you spoke of earlier the
transparency it it distinguishes the
initial effect of breaking news so I'll
take David Letterman instead of Tiger
Woods because I know Tiger better day
Tyger Tyger is a friend Tigers a friend
Tigers a friend and David is somebody I
might turn up on once every five or six
of seven eight years so with that being
said David Letterman used the principles
of social media to deal with his story
how many remember he went out front and
broke the story tonight before to the
extent that his audience didn't even
think it was serious they laughed they
actually laugh he said you know I've
been a couple things that no few women
around here they say they're gonna
extort me because they know what I've
been doing and I just want to say that
whatever however he framed it he told a
story well what did he do well CNN can
no longer now say breaking news David
told the story last night so what he did
was get ahead of the story using the
principles of social media that's a very
social media oriented principle so if
you if you utilize these tools and you
entrepreneurs think about creating
businesses around companies who need to
tell stories who need a third voice to
tell the story outside of themselves
that is a huge market is the equivalent
of being without being right its
equivalent of being a lawyer lawyers you
don't necessarily get a lawyer because
he's some expert they admitted
themselves you know what they say I'm
practicing law they're practicing
some of us some of this is going you
want to win some you're gonna lose some
so but it happens every day but if you
can start to shape the story from your
perspective from the corporate
perspective tell the story
he mentioned Comcast earlier Comcast's
when they humanized themselves with
social media it's not that all of a
sudden they became a perfect company but
what it did do was give you a voice
eager to hear your problem nothing worse
than I'm trying to get this mayweather
fight and I can't get it and all I'm
getting is this voice thing over and
over that that really upsets me but if I
can tweet out and say listen man now you
guys knew this fight was coming four
months ago what do you mean you you know
you you can't handle all the calls but
isn't that how the company makes the
money is can you explain to me why my
block cannot get through
well we didn't okay you didn't plan on
it but what's the resolution I'm in the
conflict resolution how can you solve it
his church says smartest the new is the
new gangster I'm with that that's what
it sure is smart is the new gangster
well if SWAT is the new gangster
I need a Gay Street comcast right now to
tell me how we want to solve this
problem social media is not to be taken
lightly don't let it be taken lightly
don't be guilty of this great
opportunity as entrepreneurs right now
the gold strike earlier of the eighteen
hundreds is back again and you can
either get left behind by missing the
mark
you think Pepsi shifted 20 million
dollars over to social media just for
the fun of it
is that a nice number 20 million did
that get anybody's attention or did you
continue with the current project you
were working on see as an entrepreneur
being able to shift to adapt to the
marketplace it's very important no
matter how much you love your little
idea
sometimes you got to push that ideal
aside and say it looks like here is the
sweet spot so me I know that the fashion
companies are struggling because why the
economy is down you're not spending as
much money good
hammertime that's when I hear in the
third person
hammertime I do because I am used to
engaging people in creating solutions
and marketing and promotion and
businesses - it's the foundation of the
music industry we go from grassroots to
mainstream that's what we do we have an
ideal son we can see the song at the
time it's just a song at a certain point
as a writer myself I start to think the
video by the second verse I'm writing so
I'm saying the video in in Madison
Avenue that would be the commercial so I
see the commercial - trailer now I'm
starting to see what what are they gonna
we're doing all these things
I could see initially so to apply that
to social media which my research for
what I call the holy grail of the
Internet at the time in 1995-96 that
that led me over I said this before to
Apple and I met a 14 year old kid who
was writing the code for QuickTime who
said he was gonna solve my problem back
in about 96 that was it was because I
had a huge problem there were two
outlets for my art and I didn't like
that two outlets that meant that ten
people could sit in a room and decide if
my art is worthy for you to even view it
that is a barbaric thought
it was barbaric back then and it was
even and is even more barbaric today you
don't even think the first thing you
want to do is post your video on the
bathroom on YouTube to see if you can
get a million views
we got people doing the hall kind of
thing they jump off the building with no
parachute and land on they back for
views they try to get the most views
well here we have taking time to craft
the product market mix get it on the
radio and then you go on you presented
to this one guy and he might his wife
might have told him no last night in you
know you haven't been able you know they
want you know they want four kids and he
only been able to make one I don't know
he's mad today and I come here coming in
with my happy video and thinking about
some dancing yeah I don't like it you
should have put this in Oh hold it who
made you judge injury are you telling me
that if you don't like it I can't show
it to the world well we got to fix this
so that is one of the reasons why I
started searching for companies that
would become later on YouTube it's you
know it's on that it's on YouTube when I
was there when he had about four
computers but they were about the fourth
or fifth company that I had went to over
the years since 96 or 97 trying to find
who would solve the three big problems
what were those three big challenges one
compression technology to broadband
pipes and last but not least and the
most costing it was the last mile
solution
who would pay to get the fiber from the
curve to the household well in searching
that information and trying to find that
out it led me to places like YouTube
down the road so because I was thinking
of what I would be able to do in high
was monetize my content once I had
control of it and had distribution and
able to market I was able to to make
some good strategic partnerships
networking and friends in the valley as
a result of that going forward so what
I'm saying
in a nutshell to all your entrepreneurs
because I curtail this for entrepreneur
week I'm
that whatever it is that you're working
on right now use the tools of social
media to keep your costs down to do
testing to grab the analytics behind it
and see what the people are saying don't
be afraid to to curtail your ideal I
call it a little ideal kay I'm sorry
it's a big idea but whatever it is
little or big if you're passionate about
it don't be afraid to utilize these
tools to move it forward
outside of this project I have another
project called hip knowledge if
knowledge is hidden is hidden to them
data loss which I deal with again social
issues I said earlier but social good is
also a business and there are a lot of
businesses that participate in social
good and finally again I said that last
24 another startup that I'm working on
I'm utilizing the tools of social media
to optimize with that I'll end and and
we can go back to step one for questions
and here's something very important that
I'll say to you in an inning I meet a
lot of people very you will consider
very important people I have an
opportunity to exchange ideas with very
important people very creative whether
it be the founders of Google Twitter
YouTube Nancy Pelosi last week people
who Tiger Woods Tiger Woods I'm never
swayed again I've been around as I'll
just say this as we said Tiger Woods
I've been around fame fortune people of
means since 1971 so just believe me when
I tell you that I as an individual I'm
still as proud of Tiger and what he's
able to do in his profession as I was
yesterday if the cover is pulled off of
every man will leave the women out of it
if the cover is pulled out off of every
man and every man's personal life is
exposed
what would you think of him what would
you think of your own life if all of
your quote unquote personal things are
uncovered so just saying that were type
was I wish Tiger was the best on his
road to recovery and that he continues
to be a great athlete and I'll end it
right there